after studying nearly 500 crocodiles in
Costa Rica's Palo Verde National Park
scientists found something odd males
outnumbered females four to one among
younger Crocs the number is even more
startling because a warming climate
should be skewing the ratio in the
opposite direction the mean low
temperature in Palo Verde has arisen two
point five degrees in less than 20 years
since sexing Crocs is determined by nest
temperature during incubation female
hatchlings should be outnumbering males
by two-to-one so what's causing /
masculinization in these animals
researchers think one potential source
is fish farms surrounding the park the
tilapia raised on these farms are fed
Chow laced with a synthetic hormone
called methyl testosterone or MT this
steroid is used to transform female
tilapia into males which are more
lucrative because they grow faster MT
found in croc blood and egg yolk samples
confirms the Palo Verde Crocs have been
exposed to the steroid to test if MT is
altering sex ratios researchers dabbed
varying strengths of the chemical on to
alligator eggs and then incubated them
at a temperature that should yield only
females they found that among the eggs
with the highest dosage of Mt
60% developed into males the experiment
confirms that MT does have a
masculinizing effect exactly how the
Palo Verde Crocs take up MT isn't clear
but scientists suspect that some tilapia
escaped the farm and get eaten by Crocs
which absorb the steroid and store it in
fact females produce eggs and pass it on
to their offspring
researchers say the MT tainted tilapia
isn't likely to be a health problem for
humans because the hormone doesn't
accumulate in muscle which is the part
of the fish that are cut into fillets
but evidence that MT is loose in the
environment is worrying to some
researchers since it's been shown that
low levels of male hormones can be
detrimental to pregnant women few
tilapia farms in the u.s. use MT laced
feed but it's use is widespread in the
tropics
the hormone even turned up far from the
tilapia farm surrounding Palo Verde with
a croc population in an entirely
different river system more than a
hundred kilometers away
this suggests that contaminated Crocs
are migrating or that Mt could be coming
downstream from city sewers the steroid
has medical uses and bodybuilders are
known to abuse it so scientists are
branching out to study other regions and
they plan to measure empties effects on
more Crocs and Gators they want to nail
down exactly how the steroid affects
reproduction behavior and if the
contamination is doing harm to other
creatures in ecosystems
[Music]